welcome to the huberman lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine today my
guest is dr david spiegel dr spiegel is
the associate chair of psychiatry and
behavioral sciences at stanford
university school of medicine he is also
the director of the stanford center on
stress and health
dr spiegel is both a researcher and a
clinician meaning he runs a laboratory
that studies the brain and the body and
neural mechanisms of how the brain and
body interact and he sees patients as a
psychiatrist at stanford his work is
incredibly unique in that it bridges
mind and body but it also has a
particular focus on the clinical
applications of hypnosis as you'll learn
today hypnosis is a unique brain state
in which neuroplasticity the brain's
ability to change in response to
experience may be heightened and indeed
the use of clinical hypnosis by dr
spiegel and colleagues has been shown to
improve symptoms of stress
chronic anxiety chronic pain and various
other illnesses including many
psychiatric illnesses and even outcomes
in cancer today we discuss hypnosis in
the context of what's called
self-hypnosis to distinguish it from
stage hypnosis many of you are probably
familiar with stage hypnosis which is
really about a hypnotist getting a
person to do things they would not
otherwise do
in contrast clinical hypnosis
and the use of hypnosis for the
treatment of various ailments of mind
and body is vastly different it involves
getting people to change their brain
state and to use that brain state as a
portal to make adjustments in their
brain and body and other aspects of
their biology and psychology that
benefit them and it's been shown over
and over again in studies by dr spiegel
and colleagues that those changes can
occur extremely quickly
not everybody can be hypnotized as
readily as the next and so today we also
discuss a simple test developed by dr
spiegel that can help you determine
whether or not you have a high medium or
low degree of what we call
hypnotizability
dr spiegel is truly an expert in this
area he has published over 480 journal
articles 170 book chapters on hypnosis
and on things like psychosocial oncology
which is the interaction of mind and
body in the treatment of cancer and
cancer outcomes on stress physiology
trauma and other aspects of
psychotherapy he's published 13 books so
he's truly the world expert in hypnosis
and clinical applications of hypnosis
for mind and body i'm certain that in
listening to today's episode you're
going to learn a tremendous amount about
how the brain and body interact about
various treatments for all sorts of
common ailments of mind and body and
you're going to get access to tools in
particular a tool that was developed by
dr spiegel which is the reverie app
r-e-v-e-r-i
the reverie app is currently only
available for apple but will soon also
be available for android
it does carry a nominal cost but there
is a seven day free trial if you'd like
to try it we're providing a link in the
show notes the reverie app is special in
that it is based on clinical studies and
research done in the spiegel lab at
stanford so unlike a lot of hypnosis
apps out there and resources for
hypnosis it was developed with clinical
treatments in mind today we also
discussed the use of breath work and i'm
very fortunate that my research lab at
stanford has been collaborating very
closely with dr spiegel in testing and
developing specific breath work
protocols to adjust mind and body for
things like anxiety improving mood and
improving sleep based on his incredible
and unique expertise and the clarity
with which dr spiegel communicates
information i anticipate that you will
really enjoy today's episode and that
you'll come away from it with a lot of
actionable tools some of you might be
curious what a clinical hypnosis session
looks like
and for that reason we had dr spiegel
hypnotize me a clip of that hypnosis
session is going to be posted to the
huberman lab clips channel which is
available on youtube before we begin i'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public
in keeping with that theme i'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is athletic greens
athletic greens is an all-in-one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink i've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so i'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast
the reason i started taking athletic
greens and the reason i still take
athletic greens once or twice a day is
that it covers all of my foundational
vitamin mineral probiotic needs there is
now ample evidence that probiotics can
be very helpful for supporting what is
called the gut microbiome the gut
microbiome is an aspect of our biology
in which little gut microbiota live
all along our digestive pathway and
helps support various aspects of our
biology including our immune system our
metabolic system our hormones or
endocrine system as well as what's
called the gut brain axis which is
literally communication between the gut
and the brain to support things like
mood motivation and various other
aspects of brain health
with athletic greens i get the
probiotics that i need to support a
healthy gut microbiome and the vitamins
and minerals tap off any deficiencies i
might have based on lack of certain
foods and lack of certain nutrients in
my diet if you'd like to try athletic
greens you can go to athletic greens.com
huberman to claim a special offer they
give you five free travel plaques plus a
year's supply of vitamin d3 k2 there's a
lot of evidence now that vitamin d3 is
critically important for various aspects
of immediate and long-term health and
while many people get enough vitamin d3
many people do not so the year supply of
vitamin d3 ought to be very useful for
many people and k2 has been shown to be
important for calcium regulation various
aspects of metabolic health and so forth
so again if you'd like to try athletic
greens and get that special offer of the
five free travel packs and your supply
of vitamin d3k2 go to athletic
greens.com huberman today's episode is
also brought to us by thesis thesis
makes custom nootropics
nootropic is a smart drug and personally
i'm not a big fan of the concept of a
smart drug at least not the way that
most people talk about smart drugs or
nootropics for the following reason
being smart involves various things
there is creativity there's focus
there's task switching and so on and
each one of those involves different
operations in the brain different neural
circuits different neurochemicals have
to be deployed in order for us to for
instance be very focused or for us to be
very creative or for us to be able to
switch tasks easily
thesis understands this and for that
reason they've developed custom
nootropics that are aimed at getting
your brain and body into particular
states for particular types of
work or physical activity in order to
accomplish that they've created unique
blends of high quality ingredients and
each of those blends is designed to get
your brain and body into a particular
mode such as focus clarity or motivation
i've been using thesis nootropics for
over six months now and i have to say
it's been a total game changer and very
unique from the experience of using sort
of what i call catch-all nootropics so
with thesis it's really directed toward
particular brain body states i should
also mention that they tailor those
custom blends to you so by taking a quiz
on their site they will tailor the blend
to you and your specific needs and the
things you don't want so if you want to
try your own personalized nootropic
starter kit you can go online to
takethesis.com huberman you'll take a
three-minute quiz and thesis will send
you four different formulas to try in
your first month and then based on the
outcomes with those they can update your
formulations for you that's
takethesis.com hubermann and use the
code huberman at checkout to get 10 off
your first box today's episode is also
brought to us by roka roka makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that i believe
are of the utmost quality the company
was founded by two all-american swimmers
from stanford and everything about the
design of roka eyeglasses and sunglasses
was created with performance in mind
there are a number of things about roca
sunglasses and eyeglasses that i
particularly like first of all they're
extremely lightweight you basically
forget that you're wearing them second
of all you can wear them for work for
going out to dinner etc they have great
aesthetics so you can wear them anywhere
but also for exercise you can wear them
when running or cycling and even if you
get sweaty they're designed so that they
don't slip off your face another
terrific feature of roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses is that they were designed
with the biology of the visual system in
mind we all have the experience of being
in a shaded area and then going to a
bright area it takes some time for your
eyes to adjust or to adapt
many sunglasses make it hard to see as
you move from one environment to the
next and therefore you have to take on
and off your sunglasses with roca
sunglasses you don't have to do that you
don't even notice the transitions
between those bright areas and those
dimmer areas so you can wear them
anywhere anytime and again most of the
time you don't even realize that they're
on your face if you'd like to try roka
eyeglasses and sunglasses go to roca.com
that's roka.com
and enter the code huberman to save 20
off your first order again that's roca
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout and now for my discussion with
dr david spiegel david thank you so much
for being here andrew my pleasure
can you tell us
what is
hypnosis
uh
hypnosis is a state of highly focused
attention it's something like looking
through the telephoto lens of a camera
in consciousness what you see you see
with great detail but
devoid of context
if you've had the experience of getting
so caught up in a good movie that you
forget you're watching a movie and enter
the imagined world you're part of the
movie not part of the audience you're
experiencing it you're not evaluating it
that's a hypnotic-like experience that
many people have in their everyday lives
so is any experience that really draws
us in hypnotic in that sense or
let me give a different uh
example if i'm watching a sports game
and i'm really wrapped up in the game
but i'm also in touch with how it makes
me feel in my body kind of registering
you know the excitement or the
anticipation
is that a state of hypnosis also because
you mentioned there's kind of an um a
narrowing of context
but a kind of losing of the self or is
it is to have that right yes it is true
that you're
it to the extent that your somatic your
body experience is a part of the
sport event that you're engaged with i'd
say that is a self-altering hypnotic
experience
if your physical reactions are
distracting you or
make you think about something else
that's when uh it's it's less
hypnotic-like and more just one of a
series of experiences okay
so i have to ask how did you get into
this
business of hypnosis because um i think
for most people when they hear hypnosis
or they think about hypnosis they think
of stage hypnosis right i think of
somebody with a pendant going back and
forth or people up on a stage
behaving abnormally for the
entertainment of others yeah
how did you get into hypnosis as an
interest as a practice
and if you would could you contrast the
sort of hypnosis that you do in the
clinical setting with the sort of
hypnosis that a stage hypnotist does
sure
well um
it is something of a genetic illness in
my family
both of my parents were psychiatrists
and psychoanalysts
and they told me i was free to be any
kind of psychiatrist i wanted to be so
here i am
my father was training to be a
psychoanalyst in 1943
and um
he
ran into a viennese refugee who couldn't
serve in the army but who had
studied hypnosis and actually it would
interest you
doing your ophthalmological research
he had a smallpox car right in the
middle of his forehead and he did
forensic examinations and he noticed
that some of the prisoners would focus
on that spot on his forehead and then
closed their eyes and
seemed to go to sleep but they were in
some altered state so he got interested
in hypnosis he used it forensically
and his name was gustav von schaffenberg
and
he offered to teach young psychiatrists
how to use hypnosis when they went off
in into the war
and so he trained my father um and he my
father got off the analytic couch and
asked you know
the analyst mentioned it to him that's
how he found out about it my father said
did i say something wrong in analysis
why is he talking to me no
and
he found it very useful in helping
soldiers who had acute pain when they
were wounded and helping people with
conversion post-traumatic stress
disorders
and when he came back he went back to
his training
but um he still was sort of interested
in it and he he had his one of his
supervisors was freda from reichman who
was a very famous psychoanalyst and he
he said that he had been told to stop
doing hypnosis because it would ruin his
reputation as an analyst and she said to
him what are you so worried about your
reputation for you're going to give a
course at the institute in hypnosis and
i know you're going to do it because i'm
going to take it so he was teaching
frida from richmond hypnosis and he just
kept doing it and after a while he
discovered that he was getting better
results with a few sessions of hypnosis
than he was with
daily psychoanalysis with his patients
and so he switched his his practice and
so the dinner table conversations were
pretty interesting and occasionally when
he was making a movie of a patient i
would get to watch that
and so
when i went to medical school i figured
i'll take a course there was tom hackett
who was the chair of psychiatry at mass
general was teaching it was a very
interesting course
and the day that converted me was
i was doing my rotation at children's
hospital in boston and the nurse is
telling me spiegel your next patient is
an asthmatic in room 437 or something
and i'm just following the sound of the
wheezes down the hall i go in the room
this is 16 year old girl knuckles white
bolt up right in bed struggling for
breath you can hear the wheezing she
twice had subcutaneous epinephrine
didn't work they were thinking about
general anesthesia and starting her on
steroids
and her mother's there
crying
and um i said i don't know what else to
do so i said you want to learn a
breathing exercise and she nods
and um i got her hypnotized and then i
realized we hadn't gotten asthma in the
course yet so i made up something very
complex i said each breath you take will
be a little deeper and a little easier
and within five minutes she's lying back
in bed her knuckles aren't white she's
not wheezing her mother stopped crying
the nurse ran out of the room
and the intern my intern comes to find
me and i figure he's gonna pat me on the
back and say nice job spiegel he said
the nurse has filed a complaint with a
nursing supervisor that you violated a
massachusetts law by hypnotizing a minor
without parental consent
and i thought you know oh that's nice
you know i doubt there is a law like
this so the intern says you're going to
have to stop doing this with her and i
said why he said it's dangerous i said
you're going to give her general
anesthesia and put her on steroids and
talking to her is dangerous you know he
said well you have to do it and i said
i'll tell you what take me off the case
if you want but i'm not going to tell a
patient of mine anything i know is not
true
so there was a battle over the weekend
about what to do and the the intern the
chief resident attending were all
arguing about it and on monday they came
back with a radical idea they said let's
ask the patient i don't think this has
ever been done at children's hospital
before and she said oh i like this you
know she'd been hospitalized every month
for three months in status asthmaticus
she did have one subsequent
hospitalization but after that went on
to study to be a respiratory therapist
and i thought that anything that can
help a patient that much violated
non-existent massachusetts law
frustrate the nursing supervisor had to
be worth looking into so
i just kept doing it i discovered that
there were you know all of my classmates
in medical school had just read the new
issue of the new england journal and had
some new medication to suggest
and i would you know surgeons would say
look if you can help this guy with his
pain or his anxiety anything above the
neck that's yours do it spiegel so i you
know i was having fun and being able to
learn how to help people in a way that
just otherwise was not being done and
so it got me thinking about the fact
that you know we're born with this brain
but we don't have a user's manual for it
and we don't use it nearly as well as we
can and that's something your research
is all about too
and and so i thought i want to i want to
understand this better and i want to see
what we can do stage hypnosis drive me
nuts you know they they make fools out
of people um
there was one
um
my this is a case my father was involved
he got a call from he was at columbia he
got a call spiegel you got to come see
this woman she's in the er and she's
in some kind of weird upset state that
um happened and it turned out she'd been
on the show with a stage hypnotist
who and what they do by the way is they
they cycle around you know they have a
the beginning of the show they don't
just grab somebody and say we're doing
this they get a bunch of people up they
do what amounts to hypnotizability
testing to see if people and they they
get the ones who are the most
hypnotizable so she was the one
and he said
there's now uh a little bird in your
hand and you're gonna play with the bird
and she starts to cry and scream
and he just gets her off the stage
because it's very upsetting and she's
wandering around new york city in the
middle of the night dissociated
and brought to columbia and that's where
my father saw her she was still in a
kind of uncomfortable trance-like state
and it turned out that she was the
trophy wife of a very wealthy guy and
she felt like a bird in a gilded cage
and so to her that image just
triggered all of this sense of
dissatisfaction discomfort fear about
her life and he was able to get her
reoriented and talk with her about what
she was going to do with her life but i
don't like stage hypnosis you're making
fools out of people
and you're using the fact and that's
what scares people about hypnosis they
think you're losing control you're
gaining control self-hypnosis is a way
of enhancing your control over your mind
and your body
it can work very well but because it
gives you a kind of cognitive
flexibility you're able to shift sets
very easily to give up judging and
evaluating the way you usually do
and see something from a different point
of view that's a great therapeutic
opportunity but if misused it could be a
danger too and that's what scares people
about it it is that very ability to
suspend critical judgment and just have
an experience and see what happens
that can be a great therapeutic
opportunity but if somebody's misusing
it it can be a way to harm people and
you know there are plenty of examples of
people
having fantasies imposed on them that
they come to think are realities it's
not unusual these days so
um
it's it's an ability that if people
learn to recognize and understand it can
be a tremendous therapeutic tool
i've been
stage hypnotized
and i've been clinically hypnotized many
times
through
self-hypnosis app uh we'll talk about
later and um
and then i know we have plans for you to
hypnotize me today uh you've done it
once before um and i'm very hypnotizable
as we both know right um we'll talk
about how one can engage their
hypnotizability sure but the stage
hypnosis um
was interesting this was in college you
know they brought someone out to the
dormitory and
i
recall being
one of the people that was selected
um
and uh
and engaging in very bizarre behavior
right it wasn't thoroughly embarrassing
but it was pretty embarrassing and then
being sent off the stage and as i was
exiting suddenly screaming something out
because he had planted a suggestion of
some sort
um and then i was told to look in my
pocket and there was like a i think a
torn up dollar bill there were a bunch
of things that i have vague recollection
of but it raises a um a set of questions
uh
that
really boil down to you know
as a biologist i always think that you
know there's no
there's no events in the brain there are
pro their processes and so hypnosis we
know has an induction then one is
hypnotized i imagine and then it sounds
like this woman and this example of the
the bird um and
being in being distraught in new york
city is a failure to exit the hypnotic
state do we know what sorts of brain
areas are active during the induction
the
let's call it the deep hypnosis and then
what's shutting off or changing as
people exit hypnosis yes yes we do we've
studied that we've been very interested
in that and so
we
did a study where we
selected highly and
non-hypnotizable people so we could do
the comparison and then hypnotize them
in the functional mri scanner
and we found three things characterize
the entry into the hypnotic state the
first is turning down activity in the
dorsal anterior cingulate cortex so the
dacc is in the central front middle part
of the brain as you you well know
and it's it's part of what we call the
salience network uh it's a
conflict detector so if you're
you know
engaged in work and you hear a loud
noise that you think might be a gunshot
that's your anterior cingulate cortex
saying hey wait a minute there's a
potential danger over there you better
pay attention to it so
it's a it compares what you're doing
with what else is going on and helps you
decide what to do
and as you can imagine
uh
turning down activity in that region
make it less likely that you'll be
distracted and pulled out of whatever
you're in
and in another study we found that
highly hypnotizable people even without
being being hypnotized have more
functional connectivity between the dacc
the anterior cingulate cortex and the
left dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
um so which is part of the a key region
in the executive control network so when
you're engaging in tasks you're
enacting a plan you're writing a paper
you're doing whatever you're doing
that's the the prefrontal cortex is
doing that
and so if that is coordinated we found
more functional chronic uh connectivity
so when
one is up the other's up when one is
down the other's down that coordination
implies that the brain is saying okay go
ahead i know what you're doing
carry out that plan and don't worry
about other possibilities
so two other things happen when people
are hypnotized one is that that dlpfc
has higher functional connectivity with
the insula another part of the salience
network it's a part of the mind-body
control system sensitive to what's
happening in the body it's part of the
pain network as well but it's also a
region of the brain where you can
control things in your body that you
wouldn't think you could for example we
did a study years ago where we took
people uh who were highly athletizable
hypnotized them and told them to imagine
we went on an imaginary culinary tour so
um we would they would eat their
favorite foods and we found that they
increased their gastric acid secretion
like by 87 so their stomach was acting
as though it was about to get i mean
there was one woman it was so vivid for
her that halfway through she said let's
stop i'm full you know eating these
never eaten i haven't never eaten an
actual no incredible and then we got
them to relax and think of anything but
food or drink
and we got like a 40 decrease in gastric
acid secretion so they could and that
was dlpfc through the insulin
telling the stomach you're getting food
or you're not getting food and even we
injected them with pentagon which
triggers gastric acid release and even
then in the hypnosis condition they had
a 19 reduction in gastric acid so the
brain has this amazing ability to
control what's going on in the body in
ways that we don't think we have ability
to control that's just one example so
that's the dlpfc insulate connection the
third thing that happens and this
relates to what you did on the stage
is
you have inverse functional connectivity
between the dlpfc and the posterior
cingulate cortex the posterior cingulate
is part of the default mode network it's
in the back of the brain
um and it's it's in an area whose
activity goes down for example in
meditators
and in meditation you're supposed to be
selfless you're supposed to the self is
an illusion you're supposed to let it
dissolve and just experience things and
when you're doing that that posterior
thing that is decreasing in activity the
inverse connection is i'm doing
something but i'm not thinking about
what it means for me i may not even
remember much of it if i do i don't care
that much about it and so that is part
of the dissociation that occurs with
hypnosis so it's how you put things
outside of conscious awareness and don't
worry about what it means it also adds
to cognitive flexibility you know if
you're thinking well people like me
don't usually do this
that may inhibit you from
enacting a new form of psychotherapy for
example that you've never done before
but if you're having this decreased
activity in the part of your brain that
reflects on what it means
um you're more likely to be cognitively
flexible and willing to give it a try
and that's one of the therapeutic
advantages of hypnosis as well
fascinating and it's really
i'm going to put i'm going to embarrass
you here a little bit um in the positive
sense it's your laboratory is really the
the one that's pioneered brain imaging
of hypnotic states and um it sounds like
that's my understanding is that is that
correct yeah i mean there are other
people who've done excellent research
too sure but here rainville and montreal
and several other people but we're one
of the leading lamps in
neuroimaging of hypnosis i have to ask
about attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder i get a lot of um questions
about this and i think a lot of people
just struggle with holding attention
nowadays because of um
you know interference with phones and
devices and and i of course there is a
lot of clinically legitimate adhd out
there but the way that you describe
the um dorsal anterior cingulate and the
salience network and this conflict
detector of you know
am i focusing on something or am i
splitting my attention how distractible
am i seems to relate to some extent to
activity in the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex
do people with adhd
display disruptions in elements of these
networks and
has hypnosis ever been used to
or self-hypnosis i should be um to
distinguish from stage hypnosis clinical
and self-hypnosis been used to enhance
people's ability to focus and hold
attention um because that's such a
built-in component of the hypnotic state
it's a great question there are there's
sort of two ways to think about it in
terms of enhancing focus yes it has been
very helpful um in teaching people to
just prepare your mind to narrow in and
focus on something and when you know
when you're really engaged in reading
something or you're writing a page i
mean i'll have that sometimes i'm
thinking oh god i i have to do this for
another hour other times an hour will go
by and i'll think hey great because when
you're
in that it feels game-like to you know
you're just assembling the parts of the
puzzle and putting them together it's
fun you just get absorbed that for me
that's a hypnotic-like experience when
i'm having trouble when i'm struggling
sometimes
doing things like self-hypnosis can help
i'm not an expert on adhd
my impression is that you're right that
these are people who are constantly
distracted and
rather rigid the other part of it is
they're easily distractible they're very
upset when they get distracted
and they're rather rigid in what they
want to attend to and what they can't i
think as a way of controlling this
distractibility frankly
uh i my guess is that many people with
adhd would not be that hypnotizable but
i haven't i haven't studied it so
uh it it it's possible that for some
people with that disorder training and
self-hypnosis might help but we'd have
to see how hypnotizable they were and
take it from there
i want to return to some of the
underlying neural networks and the
clinical applications but uh what sorts
of
things aside from the asthma
have you
used hypnosis successfully for
or have others used clinical hypnosis
for
and are there any particular areas of of
psychiatric
challenges or illnesses i guess they're
called
that are particularly um
amenable to hypnotic treatment
yes there are hypnosis
is very good as a problem
focused uh treatment um it's really it's
the oldest western conception of a
psychotherapy and it can be used for
specific problems in a way that's very
helpful
we found it very helpful for stress
reduction for helping people deal we're
all dealing with stress these days
and it's helpful that mind-body
connection is very helpful because
part of the problem with stress is your
perception you mentioned it earlier in a
sort of good sense you're at a you know
a football game or something and you
feel the physical reaction
that can be a reinforcing thing wow this
is exciting let's do it it can also be
very distracting so you're worried about
getting covet or you're worried about um
some
other physical problem you have and you
you notice it in your body your body
tenses up you start to sweat the
sympathetic nervous system goes your
heart rate goes up
and when you notice that you think oh
god this is really bad
and then you feel worse so it's like a
snowball rolling downhill
and and then you feel worse and then
your body gets worse hypnosis can be
very helpful in dissociating somatic
reaction from psychological reactions so
we teach people to imagine their body
floating somewhere safe and comfortable
like a bath a lake a hot tub or floating
in space and then picture the problem
that they're that's stressing them on an
imaginary screen with the ruler no
matter what you see on the screen you
keep your body comfortable so at this
point you can't you still can't control
the stress but you can control your
physical reaction to it and that starts
you feeling more in control at least
there's one thing i can manage and then
you can use it to think through or
visualize through one thing you might do
about that stressor so hypnosis is very
helpful in controlling mind-body
interaction in relation to stress um
it's very helpful for people to get to
sleep uh we're having a lot of fun with
that i
i'm getting emails from people who said
you know i haven't slept right in 15
years and now for the first time
um you know i'm listening to your app
and i can sleep at night you know so
it's very helpful and again
you know if you wake up in the middle of
the night you know i i tell people don't
look at the clock that's an arousal cue
you know you just you'll wake up more
um but a matte picture whatever you're
thinking about or worrying about on that
imaginary screen while your body's
floating so watch your own movie but
keep your body floating and many people
can use that to get back to sleep i've
been using the
self-hypnosis for sleep for a long time
and now the reverie app and we'll talk
about our relationship to the reverie
app and its uses i find it incredibly
useful for falling back asleep in the
middle of the night
and it raises a
a question um i've found and i think i
understand this correctly that one can
do self-hypnosis during the daytime
and then if there's an issue that comes
up later like so for instance do
self-hypnosis for stress reduction away
from the stressful event to prepare one
to deal with stress better right or do
uh hypnosis for improving the return to
sleep and that can be done when you
actually want to go to sleep but it's
it's a kind of a training up of these
networks right
is so is there evidence that these brain
networks actually form stronger
connections when people do self-hypnosis
over time um yeah well there's a rule in
neurobiology as you know the neurons
that fire together wire together our
friend carla schatz yes not donald hebb
by the way i keep trying to there's a
there's a there's a widespread myth in
the world that uh is unfortunately all
over the internet which is that the fire
together wired together was said by the
psychologist donald hebb donald had many
important things but it is the
neurobiologist carlos
that's exactly right yes is that
stanford but was also at berkeley and
harvard so that's so decent schools um
that but is that uh stanford um who said
fire together wired together and so she
deserves the
credit for that statement
yeah so with repeated uh use of
self-hypnosis um
one could imagine that these networks
are getting stronger i would i would
think so we don't have evidence of that
yet
but you know long-term potentiation
provides a pathway and you've described
them on your program a number of times
that allow for repeated activation of a
network to actually build new
connections that that work
and at the least even from a learning
and memory point of view you know our
you know memory is all a network of
associations that's how we remember
things um and you know the example i'd
like to give is you go back to your
grade school
and and you see these little tiny
lockers and you know the size is all
wrong and you suddenly have a flood of
memories that you you know were
obviously stored there but you just
didn't think of so
context and association is what memory
is about if you start to acquire
memories about a problem so one thing we
use hypnosis for is treating phobias for
example and the problem with people who
have phobias like airplane phobias or
you know crossing a bridge or being up
high is that the more they avoid it the
more the only source of associations and
memories
is their fear they don't have any good
experiences with it because they avoid
it you know it's like get back on the
horse after you fall off kind of thing
and and
with hypnosis if you can start people
able to manage their anxiety enough that
they can have more a wider array of
experiences they start to have a network
of associations that isn't so negative
and may even be positive so it's almost
like a uh sorry to interrupt but i have
to ask it's it's almost like a um
exposure therapy done in the mind
yeah i mean it's always in the mind i
mean even exposure to if i have a snake
phobia which i i don't i don't like
snakes but i don't think it qualifies as
a full-blown phobia i think i have a
healthy fear of snakes um but if
let's say i had a snake phobia it the
typical
approach in
would be cognitive behavioral approaches
right would be to show a picture of a
snake or then a rubber snake then a real
thing eventually the person is you know
uh holding a bow constrictor or
something like that right with that's
all in the mind because it's all
translated into nervous system signals
but with hypnosis it sounds like you can
give a number of positive experiences
without having to use any props without
having to bring any animals into the
right drive someone across the bridge is
that right yes i had a woman who was a
very successful businesswoman high level
in a corporation i had a terrible dog
phobia and um
so i had her imagine that somebody
brought in the dog to the room and i
said what are you doing and you could
see her getting tense
and she said i'm waiting to see what the
dog does and i said if somebody who
works for you comes into your office
would you freeze and wait to see what
they did
and she said of course not and i tell
them what to do you know
and i said well so you're mobilizing
yourself the power isn't with the dog
it's with you so imagine what you might
do to engage the dog and and help
control the situation and she said
thanks and and this reminds me of one
one of my favorite stories about
hypnosis that my father was seeing a
woman and who lived in midtown manhattan
and had a horrible dog phobia you know
she dropped things she'd spill coffee
you know she saw a dog she would time
her trips to the store when she thought
it was least likely that people would be
walking dogs now that wouldn't be
possible everyone is
so um
he taught her to think of dog as a
friend have a neighbor who had a dog
bring the dog over but hold the dog by
the collar and make sure
and gradually she was able to stroke the
dog and say dog friend and distinguish
between wild and tame animals there are
animals you should be afraid of a
citizen so she seemed to be doing better
he called back about three months later
and asked for her
and i said well who's calling the sunset
and he said dr spiegel
and the boy said that's weird
and my father said what's weird he said
spiegel's in heat
she she had bought a dog i love it and
named his people talk about transference
i love it
but but it really speaks to the power of
this
and it brings me back to this uh issue
um
so
what is different about
what your father did in that case uh
with this with this woman
in terms of
what happened in hypnosis
that allowed her to go from being
completely terrified of dogs to owning a
dog
and naming it after your father which i
find amusing um
but that's different than just the two
of them sitting down and talking about
it right i you know in therapy their
narrative is a huge component and in
hypnosis narrative is a huge component
right so it must be that the brain state
is what is really different because um
we'll talk about trauma in a few minutes
but
you know i think people who have trauma
or phobias certainly
um could have a conversation about it
they some of them might freeze up some
of them might lose their articulation
and so forth but what is different
about that state that combines with
narrative you think to allow these
underlying neural networks to to engage
or to change because i find this so
fascinating because we're
every attempt at uh dealing with stress
or phobia
in the clinical setting involves some
discussion about what it is
but
here we're not talking about any
medication being introduced at least not
in these particular circumstances right
so
i i just i i realize it's kind of an
obvious question like it has to be some
difference in brain activity but i find
that to be incredible the the control
variable there is
the brain state it's not
what's spoken
you're raising a couple of very
important issues andrew um
i you know we we talked earlier about
with systematic desensitization where
you you know sort of lay out a hierarchy
of things and do it one at a time i
think of this as unsystematic
desensitization because you're changing
mental states and if and i think there's
more and more evidence that mental state
change itself has therapeutic potential
we're seeing that with ketamine treating
depression a dissociogenic drug
um
we see it we know it every morning when
we wake up that problem you know you
made the mistake of reading a nasty
email at 11 pm you don't know what to do
you wake up in the morning think oh that
idiot yeah here's what i'm going to do
you know so just changing mental state
itself has therapeutic potential and i
think we underestimate our ability to
regulate and and change responses to be
cognitively
emotionally and somatically flexible and
so we do things you're right that follow
similar principles of facing a problem
seeing it from a different point of view
and you've done a really nice podcast on
trauma and stress and how you have to
expose yourself to it not avoid it as we
talked about before and then find some
way to reconnect to it to substitute
something that can make you feel good
rather than bad
so that you activate other centers of
the brain like mesolimbic reward system
and so i do that with hypnosis and you
can do it much faster people don't think
they can but they can if you're having
right now that physical experience i'm
thinking about this but i'm not feeling
as bad as i used to
that can be a powerful thing and you can
do it with hypnosis so
i had a woman came to see me who had
suffered an attempted rape it was
getting dark
she was coming back from the grocery
store and this guy grabs her and wants
to get her up into her apartment it's
outside her apartment and she starts
fighting with them and she winds up with
a basilar skull fracture he runs away
the cops come
since she hadn't been raped they left
they weren't interested and she wanted
to use hypnosis to get a better image of
what this guy looked like which is a
painful upsetting thing so
she was quite hypnotizable i got her
floating i said you're safe and
comfortable now nothing can happen that
will harm your body
but on on the left side of the screen i
want you to picture this guy and his
approaching what's happening and she
said i really the light was it was
getting dark i really can't see much of
his facial features but i do recognize
something i hadn't allowed myself to
remember
if he gets me upstairs he doesn't just
want to rape me he's going to kill me
and
so in some ways what she was seeing was
even worse so you know you're thinking
good spiegel you made her even more
frightened than she was before but as
you had pointed out in your ptsd stress
lecture you've got to confront the
trauma to to restructure your
understanding of it so on the other side
of the screen i had her picture
um
[Music]
what what are you doing to protect
yourself and everybody in a trauma
situation engages in some strategy of
self-protection you know that's the
salience network kicking in
and
she said you know what he's surprised
and i'm fighting that hard he didn't
think i would
and so she realized on the one hand that
it was even worse than she thought it
was but on the other hand that she
actually probably saved her life
and so it was a way of helping her
restructure her experience of the trauma
and make it more tolerable so that
helped with her she didn't recognize she
couldn't identify the guy but it helped
her
restructure and understand her
experience and that's something that you
can do in just talking straight out
psychotherapy
but sometimes you can do it a hell of a
lot faster and more efficiently
using hypnosis and there is one
randomized trial out of israel that
shows that adding hypnosis to ptsd
treatment actually improves outcome
so uh
it's it's a way of accomplishing things
that we understand
in the broader psychotherapy world but
much more quickly and and sometimes
effectively yeah it sounds like going
into somewhat into the state
that one is trying to deal with but then
dissociating from that state is key and
i can imagine uh and you know i've been
open about this on various podcasts i've
done a lot of uh
analysis over the years so in but in
i've experienced myself that in in those
sessions depending on how i show up to
them i might just get in kind of a
laundry list of what happened as opposed
to actually feeling anything around what
happened right um and i think people
probably vary in the extent to which
they can drop into feeling states
and it can depend on the day it can be
depend on how well uh you slept the
night before and so on there's there's
one thing i might add andrew and that is
you know there's a notion to late gordon
bauer he did we just had a memorial for
gordon um
at stanford he died about a year ago
brilliant cognitive psychologist or one
of the founders of cognitive psychology
uh at stanford and a great picture he
almost he almost became a major league
pitcher but he decided to go to grad
school instead and i'm glad he did
um but gordon
uh helped establish the concept of
state-dependent memory that when you're
in a certain mental state
you enhance your ability to remember
things about it and the sort of the bad
example of that is the drunk who hides
the bottle and can't remember where he
put it until he gets drunk again that
he's in that same mental state
people go into dissociative states uh
when they're traumatized so in a way
hypnosis is helping them remember and
deal with the memories better because
they're more in the mental state that is
more like what happened and most rape
victims will tell you i was floating
above my body feeling sorry for the
woman being assaulted below
people in traumatic episodes they just
say you know i blank out i don't know
what's happening i'm on autopilot and
that's a kind of self-hypnotic state so
when you use hypnosis to help them deal
with the traumatic memory you're making
the state they're in right there in your
office with you more congruent to the
state they were likely in when the
trauma happened and i think that is part
of what helps facilitate treatment of
trauma-related disorders i see
so that
makes me have to ask every question i
have to ask because i really feel it as
almost a compulsion then
if dissociation during a traumatic
episode is
it's a part of the adaptive strategy
right um but it creates certain issues
it creates problems right um
why would something like ketamine
which creates a dissociative state be
useful for the treatment of trauma this
is what i'm i'm confused about these
days because um our colleague carl
deisseroth who's also been on this
podcast and and his co-workers have
figured out okay there's these layer one
networks in court in the neocortex and
those are involved in the associate of
state and so we're starting to gain some
understanding of how ketamine works at a
neural level right it does seem
as if for certain populations it's a can
be a useful treatment i don't know i've
never tried it i don't know what the
current status of that is but it is
legal it is allowed at least it's fda
approved
and it's in use
why would dissociate dissociative states
be useful if this if some element of
dissociation is what um gave rise to the
trauma
trauma memory in the first place well uh
yeah carl had a brilliant paper in
nature where he it was from from rats to
humans in one paper and he showed that
there's this rhythmic discharge in the
retrosplenial region
that is associated with that is
triggered by ketamine and and the rats
actually showed
dissociative like behavior in that they
would touch a hot pad that they
ordinarily wouldn't and they didn't seem
to have much pain in their paw and he
then had a a male subject who had uh
implanted electrodes human a human
subject yeah human subject and um the
electrodes had
picked up this rhythmic
activity and when they did he would
report being in a dissociative state and
his description was it's like being a
pilot of an airplane and then i felt
myself walking out of the cockpit and
the plane was still flying and it sounds
terrifying to me
that's the thing i want to be in my body
most of the time you know
that's right but the the point is
in a way the principle andrew is like
the principle you said that you need to
reconfront
a traumatic situation before you can
modulate your associations to it so you
have to accept it except the arousal
put some boundaries around it and then
figure out how you can approach that
problem or how you did approach that
problem from a different point of view
so it does not surprise in fact we've
studied uh people who dissociated during
the loma prieta earthquake and the
oakland berkeley firestorm i remember
both of those as well yeah earthquakes
follow me and then i moved south and
then the northridge yeah i'm going to
keep them there will be one layer this
afternoon
i'm starting to dissociate
so um
dissociation does compartmentalize
experience but that means from the point
of view of treating trauma it it's an
it's an inhibition you don't engage it
it's like it happened over there and i
think what happens is that people
are sometimes too good at being able to
separate themselves from the
recollection so it's in there somewhere
it doesn't it's out of sight but it's
not out of mind it's having effects on
you but you can't deal with it you can't
reprocess it so i do think one reason
ketamine might work
is
that in fact it allows you to keep to
re-approach
the dissociative experience in a way
that you can then start to think about
and do something about it and just the
fact you can turn it on and off and
that's also where self-hypnosis is so
helpful it's not something that just
comes over you and happens to you it's
something you can make happen you can
control it you can do something with it
so you feel less helpless and out of
control the essence of trauma is
helplessness it's not fear it's not pain
it's helplessness you become an object
you become just your body you don't
control what's going on and we're not
used to that you know you and i have
discussed this this
this brilliant paper on anticipation of
breathing and it's not whether you
breathe inhale or exhale or hold your
breath it's that if you think you can
inhale and you can't
um that is really upsetting
understandably and so it's the the issue
is control and hypnosis which has this
terrible reputation of taking away
control is actually a superb way of
enhancing your control over mind and
body
i love that and it it reminds me that
naming is so important you almost wonder
if um self-hypnosis and clinical
hypnosis had been called something else
that it would have been separated out
from stage hypnosis in a way that would
make it um less uh you know less scary
weird um complicated for people to
embrace uh but yeah you know the part of
the reason for having this discussion is
i i would i've had great experiences
with hypnosis i've seen the data
you know we're talking about a lot of
clinical examples it's incredibly
powerful and it boils right down to
neural brain states right um and you
know i think in the years to come it's
going to become
more widespread
along those lines
how quickly you've described some
examples of people
getting relief very quickly
how permanent are those changes
is there a need for follow-up and
related to that i'm sure a number of
people are listening to this and
thinking wonderful i'd love to get
hypnotized for any number of different
things by
dr spiegel or somebody else expert in
clinical hypnosis but they might not
have access to you or somebody um with
similar training so
what is the power so how how quickly
does it work how long lasting are those
changes and then
is it necessary to work with a clinical
hypnotist and is it better to do that
than self-hypnosis and so on and so
forth maybe you could just give us a
contour of the of the landscape of
directed and and self-directed treatment
well
typically um
most people start by coming to see a
clinician like me it's better to see
someone who's like has licensing and
training in their professional
discipline
medicine psychology dentistry whatever
it is because there are a lot of
hypnosis out there who are just
hypnotized just hypnotist
okay and and the key issue is
somebody who can really assess what your
problem is and make sure that you're not
talking someone into reducing their
chest pain rather than getting their
coronary artery problem because they
could have a real issue there they could
right hypnosis might
adjust but wouldn't deal with the deeper
underlying issue that's right on the
other hand and typically when i use it
with people i often only see them once
or twice or periodically but not every
week and certainly not every day if they
have a pain problem and hypnosis is very
helpful for pain
um and and so
what i'm doing is identifying how
hypnotizable they are i give them a
standard brief test of their ability to
experience hypnosis
and then going through a self-hypnosis
exercise with them to deal with the
problem seeing how they respond to it
and then teaching them how to do it for
themselves
and in the old days i used to have them
use their iphone and record you know uh
the that part of the session so they
could play back the hypnosis experience
now we've developed an app uh bravery
that that uh can teach people and step
them through
dealing with pain stress uh focus uh in
insomnia and help people eat better and
and stop smoking um and both we have uh
elements that take about 15 minutes and
elements that just take one or two
minutes that people can refresh and
reinforce so
hypnosis
yes yeah and it it's one to two we're
one to two minutes now and we're finding
that two-thirds of the people find that
even just the one-minute refresher
helps them feel better they're reporting
they feel better so the nice thing is
you know right away whether it's likely
to help you or not and we've found we've
done studies looking at hypnosis for
pain relief in acute medical procedures
we did a randomized trial that we
published in the lancet
three conditions people getting arterial
cut downs to chemoembolize tumors in the
liver or visualize renal artery stenosis
you don't use general anesthesia for
this it's very uncomfortable and people
are anxious and we had three conditions
one was standard care they could push a
button and get opioids
iv is during the surgery during the
surgery the second is they could do that
plus they had a friendly nurse
comforting them so we controlled for
pleasant attention and support and the
third was we taught them self-hypnosis
for pain control so you're you're
feeling you can change the temperature
your your body is cool tingling and numb
you're floating in ice water and feeling
comfortable
or go somewhere else leave your body
here and go to a desert island and enjoy
yourself
and we found that it's about two and a
half hour procedure that after by the by
an hour and a half
the hypnosis group had reduced their
pain by 80 percent
uh compared to the standard care group
using half the amount of opioids they
had fewer complications and the
procedure took 17 minutes less time on
average to get done because not only was
the patient more relaxed so was the
treatment staff they could they weren't
dealing with someone who's struggling
and uncomfortable we measured their
anxiety and same thing the hypnosis
group i was worried they were all dead
they had no anxiety after an hour and a
half they were saying i'm fine you know
and they were fine and the and the
standard care group had five out of ten
anxiety scores at that point so we
published that in the lancet big
randomized trial um if we had a drug
that did that
every hospital in the country would be
using it now you know but there's no
industry to push it so
that's part of what helped us decide
that we needed to help people
you know do this with with reverie and
teach them how to do it and provide
interactive support for them to do it
and does it you know the question
although is does it work long term
because what we can do acutely doesn't
necessarily carry on so
we did a randomized trial of women with
metastatic breast cancer they had
advancing disease we met with them in a
support group once a week and taught
them self-hypnosis
for for stress and anxiety and pain
control at the end and by the end of a
year uh the treatment group had half the
pain the control group did on the same
and very low amounts of medication so it
lasts and they would say when i felt
that pain in my chest and thought it was
a metastasis i just did the exercise i
got myself in a warm bath and i felt
fine so
it works because it becomes a skill that
people acquire
but they can tell right away whether
it's likely to help them working with a
clinician or now using the
other ways of helping them learn to use
it as a skill so the nice thing is you
will know very quickly whether it's
likely to help you or not and if it is
you can learn to do it for yourself
that's great and we will um again
there'll be a link to reverie in the
caption that's available for apple and
android and i think um even though
there's a nominal cost there i think
that uh you know
the as you mentioned
medications and other approaches to
dealing with these problems are
quite expensive and and potential have
all the potential for side effects and
things not that some of those aren't
also useful could i before you get to
that just one thing we we've worked very
hard on the app we have an ios app for
apple
we decided to to table for a moment
redoing the android app so it's not it
was available um
when we were working through the alexa
platform
it's not at the moment but it will be
soon so i just don't want people to be
disappointed if they're looking for it
for android it's it's on our agenda but
we don't have it at the moment great
thanks for that clarification hopefully
in time for both um i get asked a lot
about um
obsessive thoughts or intrusive thoughts
i also get asked a lot about ocd
is there any evidence that hypnosis or
self-hypnosis can be used for dealing
with obsessive thoughts
sometimes there are some very
obsessional people who just turn out not
to be that hypnotizable for yeah and
it's not random they you know they tend
to be so over controlling of thought
they're all busy evaluating rather than
experiencing so i saw a few people like
that sounds like it sounds like an
adaptive uh mindset for a lot of
professions in areas and that we get
trained up in that yeah during school
you know how to obsess over the exam
obsess over the
yeah our
social interactions i mean it's part of
becoming a functional human being and
yet
you can take us down a different way we
sometimes overdo it i mean i'll tell you
one example from extreme situations uh
because
that you know you're judging evaluating
you're not letting yourself experience
including emotionally
i know somebody um who listens to the
tapes from airplanes that they go down
so they get the black box and they
listen to it
and he said to me you know that's his
profession or he does this recreation no
it's not
and because they're trying to do
accident prevention and how to handle
things and
he said that um you worry about people
panicking right you know and here these
guys know that you know they've got 30
seconds or some 45 seconds and they're
just going through their checklist he
said they're they don't panic enough
they're they're taught that this is what
you do and there is reason there's good
reason for it but sometimes they overdo
it and you know it's it's painful to
listen to this because you know what's
going to happen so
it's kind of a balance we have to hit
and some you know we sometimes we get
too emotional and too absorbed and you
don't
you're not with it enough to sort of see
other possibilities that can be a
problem but on the other hand sometimes
you're too rigid and controlled and you
don't let your emotions guide you to
what you need to do to protect yourself
or protect others so
i would say in general that people with
ocd are
in the less on the less hypnotizable
side of the spectrum they're less likely
to allow themselves to engage in enemy
and you know the typical example is the
checking with ocd for example they don't
remember
you know whether they you know locked
the door or turn off the gas in the oven
and they keep going back and they keep
checking so there the evaluative
component of the brain kind of overrides
the experiential one and um sometimes
people can get some benefit but but
they're not a group that i would select
for being the most likely to respond to
self-hypnotic approaches are our
superstitions similar
superstitions
there i think that's more there are
people who are very hypnotizable who
keep getting caught up in things like
superstitions and there
the imagination supplants the reality
and
we've seen a lot of that happening
recently and so
i i think there
um it's possible that they could be
helped by learning to sort of
see it but put it in context you know
see it from uh from a different point of
view i developed a pretty vicious
superstition when i was in college and
it was hard to break actually um i
always feel that when i talk to
clinicians i have to reveal certain
things about pathology and so you'll get
my bill later thank you yes uh it's part
of the reason i arranged this i'm just
kidding yeah i did i i had a habit of
knocking on wood for things and i
noticed it started to i would
i would um
i would sneak knocking on wood every
once in a while because i didn't want
people to think i was doing too often
and i started to realize that i it was
becoming a little bit of a reflex
and then i saw this incredible video
from ben solevsky's lab at harvard he
studies motor patterns he has these rats
that press different sequences of of
levers and turn dials in order to get a
pellet of food
but that as they do that they'll start
to introduce these behaviors that have
nothing to do with the actual lever
pressing like they'll start scratching
their and their hind quarters and things
like that and their hat and
their head excuse me they don't wear
hats and flipping their ears and this is
just like a picture before
throwing uh a baseball
that
we do this we start to incorporate motor
behaviors that are unrelated to the
outcome but we our mind somehow starts
to think that it they're necessary for
the outcome and so then you incorporate
it so i decided to break it by simply
forcing myself to not do it for about a
week and then it just seemed like a
ridiculous thing to do yeah well weak on
wood we call it response prevention and
it works because you said what what you
do is you set up a new context in your
brain where you get the outcome you want
devoid of the the extraneous behavior
yeah and i knew it was it was nuts right
i knew it was illogical right but
somehow these things take on meaning
right um so we talked about stress
reduction the utility of hypnosis uh for
stress reduction phobias pain um
possibly we don't know but for uh things
like adhd and ocd it just will depend on
hypnotizability right um you talked
about this a beautiful study on the um
a metastatic
breast cancer
outcome or patients
hypnotizability is clearly a key
variable yeah so could you please tell
us
what hypnotizability is how it's
evaluated and what the spiegel eye rule
test is okay sure so
um
hypnotizability is just a capacity
to have hypnotic experiences and we have
a test called the hypnotic induction
profile where we give a highly
structured hypnotic experience and you
know the the old tradition in clinical
hypnosis was that you
try a bunch of different things talking
walking upstairs and downstairs and
other images and time what you say to
the breathing of the subject and all
that and the more you change what you do
as a clinician
the less you can make a variation in
outcome so and it could take a long time
you know 20 minutes 30 minutes
and i just view that as a kind of
complex not very effective way of
assessing the person's hypnotic capacity
we know that the peak period of of
hypnotizability in the human life is the
latency years and childhood so every
eight-year-old is in a trance all the
time you know you call them in for
dinner they don't hear you they're doing
their thing and that's why childhood is
such a wonderful experience work and
play are all the same thing you know and
we try to make them into little adults
which i think is a terrible mistake they
and everything is fun for them they
enjoy learning they enjoy everything so
what age are they in this this is like
six to ten six to 11.
they're playful they enjoy everything
everything is sort of a game and fun
and we try to make it miserable for them
but
they've got it and then when what piaget
called um
you know a more adult cognitive
framework where we learn abstract
concepts we learn that even if one
bottle looks bigger than the other they
can have equal volume and so we start
imposing logic we're growing our dlpfc
at that point and imposing cognitive
structure on experience
some people start to lose that hypnotic
ability by the time you're in your early
20s
your hypnotizability becomes extremely
fixed and there was a study done at
stanford ernest hillgard for the phil
zimbardo did this looking at um
they they've tracked down
students who were in psych one had their
hypnotizability measured and retested
them blindly 25 years later and the test
retest correlation was you want to guess
what it was uh i'm guessing it's
i don't know 0.6
something yeah very close it was 0.7 iq
would be 0.6 on a 25-year interval so
it's more stable than iq over a 25-year
interval so once you're at that point
that's where you are
what are the factors that that lead to
that well and so what it means is that
about a third of adults are just not
hypnotizable two-thirds are about 15
percent are extremely hypnotizable and
we can measure that and give it a number
from zero to ten um and that's very
useful for some of my patients when i do
it i say look i'm sorry you're not
hypnotized but we're gonna do something
else you know medication systematic
desensitization mindfulness other things
or if they're very hypnotizable i just
go for it you know i don't do a lot of
explaining people who are low to
moderate hypnotizable like explanations
about what you're doing but then they
can still
get the benefit so it helps me
guide my the nature of my treatment with
these people now the the eye roll is my
father
um used to use an eye fixation induction
he used to say look up at the ceiling
and and now close your eyes while you're
looking up go you're very yes your
agreement yeah so he noticed he had two
patients back to back
and one was a woman who i'd seen him
work with who had
hysterical seizures she would just
suddenly start shaking and
real epileptic seizures no
pseudoepileptics i see so hysteria
hysteria and although some people have
both that is the
for some people real epilepsy becomes a
framework that gets elaborated on for
when you're stressed you have seizures
she just had pseudo-epilepsy no eeg
abnormalities and she was really
something to watch her husband had to
move his workbench near the door so that
if she started have a seizure he could
run home and and try and help her with
it it was that bad
and he noticed that when she when she
did he she did what you did when she
looked up when she would have one of her
seizure events
all you see is sclera you don't see iris
anymore
and she would start to see so he he did
a great thing with her he taught her to
have seizures everybody else was telling
her to stop he made her have one so he
hypnotized her let's go back to the last
time you had one and sure enough she'd
start to shake and gradually he'd make
them smaller and smaller so she was
learning she could control she'd have
access it's like with ptsd you know you
confront you don't avoid it you don't
suppress it you confront it and figure
out how to deal with it um
the next patient he had was a rigid
obsessional businessman
who wanted to stop you know being so
controlling and and all this
it reminded me there was a new yorker
cartoon of a driver who comes to a yield
sign and he yells never you know it's
always been
all right
and so
this guy when he tried to look up
he couldn't keep his eyes up while he
closed him and so
my
father started testing people and it
seemed that there is a rough correlation
between the capacity to keep your eyes
up while you close them and measured
hypnotizability so that people who are
listening what um might
end up and watching on video so the
speaker eye roll test involves looking
up at the ceiling so it's tilting the
head back i'm tilting my chin back and
looking up at the ceiling now but i'm
also directing my eyes upward and my
eyes are open and then
the the eye roll test involves then
closing the eyelids while the eyes are
open or open and whether or not the eyes
roll back and as you said it then you
see sclera the white clear the white
part that means you're very hypnotizable
or moderately hypnotizable right whereas
if the eyes move down and you see iris
the colored part of the eye as the eyes
close less hypnotized right correctly
and you can look this up online there
you just put spiegel eye roll test and
um
and you'll find it and and we are also
going to do an actual um example of
hypnosis um on video later right
so it's it you're asking the brain to do
something difficult to
to keep the eyes up while closing the
eyelids and so that's contradictory
signals for the third fourth and sixth
cranial nerve nuclei that control eye
movement you said the third fourth and
six yeah cranial nerve nuclei and and so
they're they're you're suspending one
activity while
asking them to do another
and eye movements have a lot to do with
levels of consciousness you know the
periaqueductal gray surrounds these
cranial nerve nuclei
and um
when we you know we close our eyes when
we sleep we have rapid eye movement when
we dream most drugs that affect level of
consciousness can affect eyes and eye
movements either the dilation or
contraction of the pupils depending on
whether it's a stimulant or an opioid
stimulants make the people's baby right
yeah this like cocaine amphetamine right
exactly exactly and and opioids
you get constricted
pupils this is what parent you know
parents looking at their kids coming in
the door late at night they're looking
for
right substance abuse that's right so so
there's something about the eyes that
has a lot to do with level of
consciousness i mean obviously you close
your eyes when you go to sleep you have
rapid eye movement when you're dreaming
so it's not surprising and there's
there's an old zen practice called
looking at the third eye
and i think part of the reason that this
happens is where you're looking up in
inside it's like there's a third eye
between the other two in your forehead
um and i think it's because
we're visual creatures you know we're
we're pretty pathetic from a physical
point of view you know many animals can
outrun us you know
um and or outsmell us or see eagles can
read could read a newsprint at a 100
yards and we can't you know it's so um
our major defensive sensory input is
vision
and that's why you know animals predator
animals
have eyes in the front of their heads so
that they have very good detailed
division
vision of prey whereas prey animals like
deer have eyes on the side of their
heads so they don't see things that well
but they have a much bigger range
of uh potential to see threat and we
mainly use in fact it's interesting
there have been social anthropologists
say why do we gather where we do you
know on on coastlines and you know at
the edge of a forest or something it's
because you've got protection in the
back something can't attack you from one
side and you have a big vision of what
might threaten you and we tend to like
be attracted to those kinds of
uh physical situations so i love vistas
we love this videos are very calming
they take us into that panoramic vision
that's right
i didn't know this but it turns out that
most of the scenic spots at any location
in national parks and were where people
naturally aggregated it wasn't um which
makes sense
you know but that those um signs and
locations were built up around people's
tendency and animals tendencies oh
really to aggregate there yeah there's
an interesting book on the history of
the national parks that that says that
they didn't give a uh a research study
to support it but there was no google
maps obviously that's very interesting
yeah panorama and and visual boundaries
are really interesting i i think so that
the eyes as we both know are two pieces
of the central nervous system of the
brain right outside the right i used to
say that the eyes are outside the skull
and and a uh a neuro-ophthalmologist
said um there wrote to me and um
vehemently pointed out that they are
outside the cranial vault so you know
they're outside the cranial valve but
there are two pieces of brain they're
out there and so
you mentioned cranial nerves three four
and six this isn't in our anatomy course
but um but maybe we could go a little
deeper there so there's you said there's
contradictory activity looking up is
controlled by um
uh
the one set of cranial nerves and then
the closing of the eyelids is cl is
controlled by another cranial nerve no
it's the same one i think it's six that
that um you you close when you close
your eyes
you
activate um
no it's the face i guess it's the facial
nerve it's uh seven seven yeah yeah but
you're
looking up you're activating the muscles
um that
force your eyes to look up and the the
closing your eyelids normally relaxes
those it relaxes that upper movement
because your eyes are closed and you
don't need to do it so you're breaking a
con a usual customary insider the
rubbing
hey i can't even do it see it's like
um that's rubbing your tummy and patting
your head it's it's a bit there's a bit
of a conflict there right but clinically
it's been a good probe for you and yeah
and for your father so was it spiegel
senior or spiegel that's spiegel senior
that developed this big role and um but
the key issue is this that normally when
we close our eyes also we're going to
sleep you know you're you're not worried
about what's going on in the world
anymore here you're maintaining resting
alertness so you're focusing but you're
turning inward that's an unusual state
normally we don't we close our eyes
periodically we have to but
um when you close your eyes for some
period of time it's normally to go to
sleep and you're not worried about you
know detecting risk or threat
so it's an interesting state because
you're turning inward basically you're
looking up you're shutting your eyes and
you're allowing whatever happens outside
you to happen and focusing on what's
going on inward so it's a i think it's a
signal to your brain to turn inward
very interesting um and meditation of
course could be done with eyes open but
almost always is done with eyes closed
yes um that's right very interesting so
you can very quickly determine whether
or not someone is highly hypnotizable
not at all hypnotized we said about
two-thirds of people can be hypnotized
right um obviously a third cannot and
but within the two-thirds that can
there's a range and you said 15 percent
of people fall into this highly
hypnotizable category that i seem to be
a member of um and
does repeated use of self-hypnosis or
clinical hypnosis increase or change
hypnotizability for those that can
access it in the first place i would say
in general it may increase a little bit
but not a hell of a lot and it's not
worth the effort to increase your
hypnotizability at that point it's worth
trying to deal with the problem you're
dealing with so you can get better at
using it at the level that you have
there was a study done in which they
tried to train people to be more
hypnotizable and
you know obviously there are subjective
and behavioral components to the test
you can learn to do a little better on
them but what we found was when we
reanalyzed this data that we could
account for three times the final score
based on the initial hypnotizability
measurement rather than whether or not
they had been trained to do better so
you can improve it a little but it's not
worth the trouble got it
along the lines of eyes and eye
movements um a lot of interest out there
about emdr eye movement desensitization
reprocessing um
uh shapiro herself was uh working not
she wasn't at stanford directly but was
the local to stanford yeah i think in
palo alto um so
what are your thoughts on emdr where is
it useful where do you think it's less
useful
um are there things that emdr could be
combined with to make it more
useful um
you know we get you know the listeners
of this podcast come to
uh i think come to the podcast with a
range of backgrounds and interests um to
me it makes sense
uh why emdr lateralized eye movements um
might work given the newer data that it
can suppress amygdala activity in some
animals and animal models and um in
humans as well but it really hasn't been
explored much neurally i've heard things
like it coordinates the two sides of the
brain which it to me is a it's just a
throwaway i don't think there's any
evidence that coordinating the two sides
of the brain is better than not
coordinating i wouldn't be speaking
right now if the two sides of my brain
were were well correlated because
language is lateralized so right i've
heard that it mimics rapid eye movements
during sleep but actually it doesn't so
um right but i have heard um people talk
about their positive experiences with
emdr what are your thoughts about yeah
yeah yeah you had a good comment on that
in one of your recent podcasts and i
i'll tell you you know
one way i sort of think about it uh from
a bemused point of view is the old you
mentioned it earlier the oldest sort of
idea of a hypnotic induction was a
dangling watch right you know and to
watch um and um in fact there was enough
concern about it that when automobiles
were invented there was a movement to
prevent
installing windshield wipers
because people were afraid that they
would be hypnotized if they watch the
windshield wipers go back and forth on a
car
now it turns out fortunately that you
tend not to look at the windshield
wipers you keep looking through the
windshield
and so we have windshield wipers today
but
that movement is what exactly used to be
a hypnotic induction i think there is a
lot of hypnosis in in emdr
and i think it's a combination of that
with you know exposure-based treatments
where you use the mbr to think about it
you tend not to process
the experience as much and just do the
physical part of it which i personally
think is a drawback and
every study i've seen that was a
dismantling study there's no question
that people who go through mdr many of
them get better with trauma-related
problems and the va has a big program
using it and so on
but every program that has dismantled
going through the treatment with having
the lateral eye movement
has shown that the lateral eye movement
doesn't add anything to it and toward
the end of her career uh francine
um was doing now contralateral touching
or something it wasn't eye movements
anymore it was other things so
i i tend to think that emdr
is another form of exposure-based
therapy for trauma but
as you've implied with the exception of
this possible new data it certainly
doesn't have to do with rapid eye boom
and sleep and i don't i don't think
moving the eyes is the issue i think
it's a way of sitting down and
confronting trauma and i would rather
that the trauma itself be processed a
bit more than often happens in emdr so a
lot of people have gotten therapy some
of them have been helped francine used
to originally claim that just one
session would desensitize people and do
it and that's clearly not true i see a
lot of people who said yeah it helped
for a while but i you know i need more
so i i
i think
it became a kind of a
you know overly simplistic approach to
understanding brain physiology and that
part is
wrong and and you know the interesting
thing you know you mentioned suppressing
amygdala activity
it's very interesting that my
late friend ellen hopson who's a
brilliant sleep researcher you know
well i don't know him but i read his
book when i was in college about the
chemistry of sleep right and the
uh similarities between dream states and
hallucinations yeah and uh it's one of
the reasons i got into this business yes
well i worked with him in a macarthur
mind body network for many years and
he's a brilliant guy points out that
we need to get into primarily a
parasympathetic state to go to sleep um
that we have to shut off
shut off the sympathetic nervous system
and and that's why a loud noise wakes
you up when your heart rate goes up and
all this so he was brilliant at
documenting what happens in the brain of
sleep he pointed out something also very
interesting about dreams
which is
that the stories and dreams and even the
images and dreams can change all over
the place in crazy ways but usually the
affect is constant
so usually if it's a frustration dream
whatever happens you wind up frustrated
and if it's a you know enjoyment dream
you enjoy whatever is going on so
there's a odd consistency and affect in
the dreams that that you don't have
uh in other states and the idea of uh
lateral eye movement suppressing
amygdala activity would kind of fit with
that that you don't allow intrusions
of fear and anger
and upset injury it may be there all the
time but it may not be there when you
think it should be so why is it that you
can be falling off a building and
somehow not that scared you know you're
just having this experience of flying in
a dream so
i i think
there may be something going on about
regulating affect but there are we have
elaborate and better ways to regulate
affect
great so
emdr might incorporate some elements of
hypnosis by so the lateralized eye
movements perhaps by way of suppressing
the amygdala this fear associated center
might bring people into a more
parasympathetic calm state so it might
be pseudohypnosis and then exposure
therapy through the discussion about the
issue right okay
more research needed on emdr out there
and
obviously
something that's come up a lot in this
discussion and in our
discussions that i'm have the great
fortune of talking to you every week is
uh and working together is
this idea of
getting close to the phobia getting
close to the trauma re-experiencing it
as a portal to then adjusting the
response to it and rewiring something so
the troubling thing or the horrible
thing is no longer as horrible to us
that but that the
the repeating theme is we can't
expect to get over something without
getting really close to it maybe even
experiencing it
somatically
nowadays we hear a lot about you know
triggers and trigger warnings and um
certainly one can understand why those
are why those exist but it seems like
there's a in the general population
there's this idea that we want to move
away from anything that upsets us and
yet i think it's fair to say even though
i haven't gathered the statistics that
on the whole that the human beings are
becoming more and more anxious and more
and more stressed
perhaps uh because of but certainly in
parallel with the fact that we're trying
to move away from troubling things
troubling things so
i've heard you say before
that it's in terms of therapeutic
approaches it's not just about the state
you get into but whether or not you
brought yourself there voluntarily
that's exactly right so the this element
of deliberate self-exposure deciding i'm
going to confront the trauma i'm going
to confront the pain i'm going to
confront the insomnia i'm going to
confront the you know and fill in the
blank
and then
readjusting one's emotional response
right up next to that troubling thing
that seems to be the the hallmark of
this treatment and um
if i'm thinking about it correctly of
pretty much all treatments for getting
over stuff
if people don't have access to a really
good clinician like yourself
how should they carry these thoughts and
these ideas i mean i think almost
everybody of any reasonable age has
memories or things that upset them but
we learn to suppress them
what does one do
obviously the reverie app has approaches
to dealing with some of this
inside of the app but how does one start
to think about actually dealing with
something like this and avoiding the
hazards of just kind of reactivating a
lot of painful experiences because a lot
of being a functional human being is
also going to work each day interacting
with people and not bringing one's
trauma you know and dumping it out all
on the table or or being able to just
function is so crucial so how do you
think about this as a clinician
um well you know i the image that comes
to mind is the greek myth of pandora's
box you know that it opened and the
furies got out and you couldn't put them
back in
and we have this kind of fantasy that
once you get into these memories they'll
take you over and you'll never get them
back in the box
and i think that's wrong you know we
people who use hypnosis say that there
are ways to present things to people
that will be helpful in ways that won't
and one real mistake is to tell someone
don't think about purple elephants you
know what are you thinking about you
know it doesn't work so you want to find
a way to feel in control of the access
and to define what happened on your own
terms
um and so i'm not a big fan of trigger
warnings i think we're going crazy over
you know this could be upsetting that
could be upsetting yeah there are lots
of things that are upsetting you know
the average kid has watched 20 000
murders and by the time he's 20 years
old watching television and movies these
days so you know we see terrible things
and and
it's not a matter of are you exposed to
something that's upsetting but how do
you handle it what do you make of it and
are you feeling in control it's not like
you know what uh what putin is doing to
his his rival in russia you know forcing
him to watch propaganda movies 10 hours
a day while he's imprisoned it's a
matter of
thinking um
about a problem in a way that leaves you
feeling you understand it better you're
in more control you can turn it off when
you when you want you can turn it on
when you want and so we have to in life
deal with stressful things there are
studies karen parker at stanford has
done some wonderful
studies with primates about stress
inoculation that if you separate
a baby monkey from his mother for two
hours a day and then reunite them
and then you stress that baby monkey
later
they actually handle stress better
there's less cortisol arousal in the
face of the stress stress inoculation
has been called so
mere exposure to trauma or stress it's a
part of living anyway we can't avoid it
even if we'd like to and um
it's not pleasant it's not great but
it's sometimes things you need to learn
about life and if you can find an
algorithm for
facing it putting it into perspective
dealing with it you become a stronger
person not a weaker person so this idea
that college students are such fragile
flowers that if you talk about a sexual
assault or something you know you're
doing something terrible to them it's
just wrong and and i think we need to
build our ability to recognize and
manage stress and you can't do that
without doing it you can't learn you
can't ride a bicycle without taking the
risk of falling off it you know and so i
think that's the way i think of dealing
with distress yeah i really appreciate
you saying that i uh was you and i were
both at a gathering let's say where um
this issue was being discussed and
around an issue of a of a publicized
sexual trauma and um you made an
excellent case for why
it this stuff can't be pushed under the
rug
um and that actually in my observation
led to a lot of healing for the people
that and the families of people that
suffered from this and the um i do think
people are resilient they
but we don't really teach how how to
think about feelings you know we don't
you know we're told that we need to feel
our feelings but then again
we are also told that feelings don't
hold all the information and so i think
that as you mentioned there's no
operating or user's manual for this
nervous system thing um brings me to
another issue which is the mind-body
connection something that we're very
interested in and you've done extensive
work on you know
we all like to think that getting more
in touch with our body would be a great
thing learning to intercept paying
attention to our internal landscape
would be a great thing but as we often
discuss um when we're feeling lousy
then being really in touch with that
lousy feeling may or may not be a good
thing right um so how should we think
about mind body it i can see examples in
hypnosis from your descriptions of
hypnosis where
uh you want to unify the mind-body
connection feel what you're thinking
think what you're feeling etc but i
could also um point to
elements within the hypnotic process in
which you are actively un trying to
uncouple those
so it sounds to me like this whole mind
body thing is a bit more like a car you
can't say that um 40 miles per hour is
the optimal speed it kind of depends on
the road you're on and the turn you may
or may not be taking right um how should
we think about mind body
in terms of uh you know navigating daily
life what do you think is the adaptive
way to to conceptualize the mind body
it's a big question it is it's
it's a very interesting one um i i guess
i think um
that it's a matter not of you know
absolute control but more control that
that um
we need to think of our brain as a tool
and and our body signals as tools as
well
to help us understand um what's going on
in the world what we need what matters
what's important what isn't
uh but also something that can be
managed not simply
you know absorbed
and so
hypnosis i think is a kind of limiting
case
where you can push it about as far as we
can push it
in terms of regulating pain pain is a
you know is a good example of that you
know
obviously you need to pay attention if
you just broke your ankle you better pay
attention to it and get help or you're
having crushing substernal chest pain
you better do something about it but our
brain
is sort of programmed to treat all pain
signals as if they were novel pain
signals if it's a sudden new problem
that needs to be attended to
i teach people to
to think of the pain and categorize it
see it is it does it does the pain mean
that if you put weight on this you're
going to
re-injure your ankle for example or does
it simply mean that your body is healing
and the pain is a sign that
gradually things are getting back to
normal and and so you can modify the way
you process pain based on what your
brain tells you the pain means and
that's true for emotional pain as well
and particularly where i think
a strategy that really helps
is if you think of uh an interpersonal
problem or a threat of something coming
as as a an opportunity
to do something to ameliorate the
situation so it's not just it's
happening to you but something that you
can influence and do something about
so it's
blending the receptive with the active
response that i think can make a
difference so you try and process it in
a way that gives you a deeper
understanding of what's happening you
face it but you also say this is an
opportunity for me to do something about
it and the minute you realistically
enhance and this doesn't mean imagine a
way a heart attack it means
figure out how to rehabilitate from a
heart attack or a broken leg or
something like that in a way that you
get as much control into the situation
as you can
i love it
um
grief
grief is one of those states that is
very hard to
remove oneself from you know and a lot
of people ask me how do i deal with
grief and i'm not a clinician so i'm
deferring to you uh on the one hand
actually someone at stanford recently um
came to me and said you know my mother
passed away and i had a sibling that
passed away and they were the only
people that i had and i'm also living
alone and i'm challenged with a number
of things and um they look like they
were holding it together um
very well in fact given what they were
describing um and on the one hand uh i
i well i certainly point out that i'm
not a clinician but i said on the one
hand you could imagine that it would be
necessary and useful to go into the
grief state if you want to transition
through it right um
on the other hand um there i've heard
before that the cathartic model of just
really
diving into an emotion can also be
potentially hazardous if you don't have
any anchors um to
grab onto
what what is the view of psychiatry or
your view of grief and how to deal with
grief because i think grief is is one of
those all-encompassing emotions for many
people yeah
it is and it's a very important natural
necessary stage of life and the reason
we have all these grief rituals you know
from
burials and
memorials and headstones and sitting
shiva and other things that people do
it's a way of
making it real that an incomprehensible
loss has to be comprehended you know you
have to realize that you're now going to
have to live life without your loved one
your parent your sibling whoever
and we've all go gone through this at
one time or another i certainly have
and it's very hard to just come to terms
with but
one principle is to sort of say
it it's not it's never all or none it's
more or less so yes it's all or none
that you've lost a loved one but i ask
people as part of their grieving
to say to themselves and i do this in
hypnosis sometimes too
you've lost them but what have they left
you with what what have they bequeathed
to you even though they're gone and i'll
sometimes ask them to say if your mother
could be here right now what would she
say to you
how would she feel about your life now
what would she advise you to do
so in our support groups for women with
advanced breast cancer we we lost people
and and i got to tell you that we were
warned by oncologists that we
demoralized people that
i mean they were wonderful oncologists
but there are some that were very afraid
that that we would
harm them in some way because they you
know the mortality rate is fairly high
with metastatic breast cancer they're
going to watch people die of the same
disease and you'll demoralize them and i
so we actually measured their emotion
and the content of speech every five
minutes throughout a bunch of groups to
make sure that wasn't happening what we
found was that they talked about more
serious issues but the mood didn't
actually get worse and we found in
general that expressing negative emotion
on the long run helps people be less
anxious and depressed over time and
we've shown this in randomized clinical
trials so it's not just my clinical
impression
and and um what we what we try to get
them to do
is to face a loss
live with the emotion that comes with it
but also see that the reason it hurts so
much is how much that person gave you so
we would do a self-hypnosis exercise at
the end of the room say i want you to
get your body floating safe and
comfortable now picture mary and and um
sit with the feeling of sadness that
she's no longer with us
and we do that for a few minutes and
then we'd say on the other side picture
one thing she left with you that you
still have that you carry on in your
heart her tradition of what she gave to
you
and so just seeing it not as a complete
loss but as a real loss a painful loss
but one that helps you to reflect on
what you gained from her and knowing her
um i think can be very helpful in the
grieving process that's very helpful the
way to conceptualize it um couple quick
questions um
can children be
safely hypnotized or do self-hypnosis
they it it's sometimes harder for them
to do self-hypnosis they need more
structure to do it you've got a share
your dorsal atopy frontal cortex with
him a little bit but yes absolutely
children can be very hypnotizable and
i know pediatricians who use it
wonderfully all the time they get them
to focus on something else
so they're going to have to give them a
shot or draw blood or something and
they'll say
i'm going to press your happy button and
presses their belly button and they
start to giggle the way kids do and
meanwhile the nurse is drawing the blood
and they don't even notice it um
dentists good dentists can use it to
help kids with fear and pain so yes it
can be very effective for children we
did a randomized trial i have a
publication in pediatrics my late sister
who was a pediatrician
who and who always used to joke that
she was the only one in our family who
was a real doctor you know
um i said i gotcha i got a paper in
pediatrics
and and the paper was children having to
undergo avoiding cystourethrograms so
there the the anatomy of the kidney if
you'll forgive me is sort of interesting
in in that the the ureter that goes into
the bladder
normally goes into the bladder at an
angle and so that means that when the
bladder contracts to expel urine it
automatically closes off the ureter
because it's sideways to the bladder
some kids are born with it perpendicular
and then you'll get reflux into the
kidney and
some children outgrow it some need
pretty complicated surgery to fix that
and so you you
image them every year or so to see
whether they're getting kidney damage or
not
and it's a pretty miserable experience
you're a nine-year-old girl you have to
go online on a hard cold table have
strangers pull your legs apart and stick
a catheter into your
urethra and hold in the bladder and then
expel urine and so you get into these
struggling fights and of course the more
they struggle the more they constrict
and it makes it harder to do it so um i
was asked if we could
test it so we did a randomized trial at
children's hospital
they either got training in
self-hypnosis i would have meet with
them and the mother of the week before
we find out from the kids where they
like to be and i'd say you're going to
play a trick on your doctors your body's
there you're somewhere else go visit
your friend go to disneyland do
something else and the mother would work
on this with me at the head of the table
and we found that these children were
much easier to image one got so relaxed
that so your guy with he said normally
it takes us 10 minutes to get them to
pee after they're doing this she was so
relaxed she started peeing before i
could even get the bedpan under her and
i had to clean up the table you know and
they also 17 minutes shorter procedures
and that's a long 17 minutes for a
little kid
so
it can be very effective with children
they're less anxious they have less pain
and
get through these difficult procedures
very well that's great
has hypnosis ever been done in uh for
couples like couples therapy i'm
thinking of pretty much every clinical
setting here both people have to be
hypnotizable of course
but the reason i ask about this is next
i'm going to ask about psychedelics and
there's a lot of interest in
coordinating states through the use of
of drugs of different kinds
we actually do this when we treat
depression right you have a depressed
person with a family members who are not
depressed and you say well let's make
them all uh not depressed
right i mean but but in all and i'm only
half kidding there because that is kind
of the underlying logic in some sense
but um are you aware of any um
of any coordinated hypnosis that's
interesting i i've done plenty of it in
groups not now with couples you can
hypnotize large groups
yeah yeah are we hypnotized right now
yeah you are and i i hope you've been
enjoying it
um
uh i but the the the metastatic breast
cancer there was a group of like 10
women who would meet once a week and we
would all go into hypnosis together
i didn't realize that you were
hypnotizing them collectively yes yes
right fascinating and and that you know
if anything i think it brings out the
best in people's abilities because it's
a shared social experience and
and they would talk about it afterwards
and so yes that's absolutely doable yeah
and i don't want to focus on
psychedelics specifically maybe that's a
topic for a future episode but is there
any basis for combining hypnosis with
uh drug therapies
inside of the hypnotic episode so i
realize that some patients of yours
might be prescribed antidepressant or a
medication for for some purpose uh maybe
same or different than the hypnosis is
being directed toward but is there any
evidence that if people are um relaxed
through the use of a um propranolol or
some you know one of these many things
in the psychiatrist's kit that hypnosis
can be more effective
well
interestingly one study that i haven't
mentioned is we did
spectroscopy on people who were
hypnotized and we found
that there was a correlation between
hypnotizability
and gaba
activity in the
anterior cingulate cortex which fits
with turning down activity so to the
extent that we can self-medicate and
gaba receptors basically are doing what
benzodiazepines do to the brain uh that
can happen when people are hypnotized so
you're saying inside of the hypnosis you
you have neural evidence that there's a
kind of a
sedative effect of hypnosis at the
chemical level yeah right right people
who are more hypnotizable have more of
those gaba receptives and it's related
to the degree of their hypnotizability
um
in terms of there have been studies
where they try to give people
medications as well
and the interesting thing with
benzodiazepines which activate
inhibitory activity in the brain
if you're very anxious it might improve
your hypnotic response a bit if you're
just so anxious and generally you can't
do it if you're not very anxious it
actually inhibits hypnotic activity
because you get sort of sedated and just
out of it and you can't focus your
attention as well so
by and large
we don't use drugs as an adjuvant to
hypnotic experience most of the time you
don't need to and sometimes it can make
it worse rather than better
some there's some evidence that
mild stimulants might enhance hypnotic
responsiveness a little reliably but too
much well again scatter attention and
you'll have less control over it so
the the they might be adjuvants but i
frankly think hypnosis is more of a
replacement than a need of
supplementation
your laboratory my laboratory have
um well
sort of snuck into your lab and they're
trying to uh merge the two it's been a
lot of fun and sure you're learning a
lot about um the power of respiration of
breathing to shift brain states not just
during breathing
protocols but um at all times and we
will do an entire episode about those
protocols i think
after um
those are published and
and so on but
breathing itself is um you've described
as a bridge between conscious and
unconscious states right and um so i
have to ask how
how important is the patient's breathing
pattern how closely are you monitoring
their breathing pattern
how closely do you monitor your own
breathing pattern as you're inducing
hypnosis put simply what is the role of
respiration in shifting the brain's
state
during a hypnotic protocol
yeah that's very interesting you had a
great show with jack yeah jack feldman
uh
and he he is and and the the issue
um
i i watch it um i try it
the work that we're enjoying doing
together shows that there are breathing
patterns that may
increase sympathetic arousal um or may
decrease it may come in with you know
cyclic sighing seems to actually where
you have more time spent exhaling than
inhaling
seeing and there's reason to believe
that it induces parasympathetic activity
because you're increasing pressure in
the chest
and
therefore
allowing the heart to slow down because
blood is being returned to the atrium
more easily
i do use it i ask people to take a deep
breath as part of the induction and then
slowly exhale and partly as a result of
our research together i'm emphasizing
the slow exhale more
as part of an uh some
to enhance the idea in the induction
that this is a period of relaxation
because i think they
are inducing that and perhaps perceiving
it as well
so there's no
you're absolutely right that
breathing is very interesting because
it's right at the edge of conscious and
jack talked about that too of conscious
and unconscious control that it will go
on automatically but we can control it
and so it's a kind of way for us to
demonstrate to ourselves
greater ways of
modulating our internal state
so you can either do it thinking about
it the way we do with pain control and
hypnosis
or you can do it to some extent by
taking charge of your breathing and
doing things that will produce a change
that you want to see happen in your body
so i like it because it's right at that
margin where you can enhance
for me i like that as a way of
augmenting hypnosis more than medication
i think this is a powerful way of doing
that great i'm really excited to see
where all of this goes yes breathing
vision bodily states uh clearly the yeah
and
directed mental
focus seem to be the key elements of
hypnosis am i missing any any other
ingredients yeah it's i think that's
right
breathing vision how you change your
vision
and you don't you know
typically you're in a physically relaxed
state
but frankly there are people at the peak
of performance including physical
athletic performance or musical
performance when they're in hypnotic
states too you know i've talked to
classical pianists who say
i'm not think if i start thinking about
what my fingers are doing now i screw up
you know i'm floating above the piano
thinking about the nate the tone that i
want to feel exuding from the instrument
so that's a hypnotic-like state too and
and many athletes in who are
in peak performance are just
flowing with it they're they're not
they're not thinking step by step what
am i doing
and that's when you're doing your best
or you know when when we're
working or uh
giving a talk and doing it well
we're in a hypnotic-like state so it
doesn't it it usually
requires uh but doesn't necessarily
require physical comfort or quietness it
can sometimes be intense activity
incredible
well um
this has been an amazing discussion i've
learned so much as i always do from you
um where can people learn more about how
they can get hypnotized uh we mentioned
reverie we will put a link to it
r-e-v-e-r-i
dot com is the way to access that or
it's the reverie app from the app store
is the other way reverie.com is the
website you can get to it through that
or download the reverie app from the app
store great um
so currently on apple hopefully soon
also on android but in the meantime um
what if people are interested in
exploring clinical hypnosis working with
you or or somebody similar is there a
centralized resource that people can go
to to find um really
well-trained hypnotists there are two
good professional organizations uh that
will help you with that one is the
society for clinical and experimental
hypnosis
and i think that's s c e h dot u s is
there we will we'll look it up and
provide a link and the american society
for clinical hypnosis and they both
provide
referral services for professionals
um you can look it up i would just say
in general look for someone who is
licensed and trained in their primary
professional discipline psychiatry
psychology
medicine dentistry
and who has training and interest in
using hypnosis uh is is a way to do it
great and then one more question and
then a comment um the question is will
you be my psychiatrist
i'm honored
it's a tall task
i might be the
the most stubborn patient i think the
hardest work's already been done andrew
thank you you're fine i appreciate that
well um and the final thing is as a
comment um first of all
thank you so much for being here today
for sharing your knowledge i hope we can
do it again and again i hope so i love
working with your laboratory and with
likewise because when you speak i learn
and i learn and i know others do as well
we will put resources to get to you but
i also just want to say thank you for
doing the work that you do um it's an
incredible thing that in this
world where we are discovering so much
about how the body works you know the
mind is still
rather mysterious and people are
struggling with a lot of things but also
i think people are really excited about
applying tools like hypnosis to
perform better feel better mentally and
physically and so you've pointed us to a
tremendous amount of resources and
how these tools work and where they've
already been demonstrated to work so
just
thank you i know this is your
life's professional uh commitment in
life and and we all benefit so well
thank you but it's been a real joy for
me to be collaborating with you and for
you to be using your precision and
knowledge about neuroanatomy
neurobiology to address problems that
often people who are that disciplined in
in the primary nor biological end aren't
as interested in as you are and so it's
really been a pleasure to try and
you know bring together what we both
know from these different perspectives
to build something uh that neither of us
could do alone and so it's been a real
joy for me to do it thank you i'm
honored thank you thank you very much
david you're welcome
thank you for joining me today for my
discussion with dr david spiegel i hope
you found it as fascinating as i did
and if you'd like to see the video of dr
spiegel hypnotizing me
in what constitutes a abbreviated
clinical hypnosis session you can go to
the huberman lab clips channel on
youtube
also if you'd like to check out the
reverie app for self-hypnosis designed
by dr spiegel and colleagues you can go
to reverie that's r-e-v-e-r-i
dot com to see the reverie app there's
also other information there about the
scientific studies that support the
reverie app if you're enjoying and or
learning from this podcast please
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a terrific zero-cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on apple and or spotify and on
apple you have the opportunity to leave
us up to a five star review please also
leave us comments and feedback as well
as suggestions for guests that you'd
like us to host on the hubermann lab
podcast in the comment section on our
youtube channel please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
of today's episode that's the best way
to support this podcast we also have a
patreon that's patreon.com
andrewhuberman and there you can support
the podcast at any level that you like
on many previous episodes of the
huberman lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep and focus
and various other aspects of brain and
body health and performance one issue
with supplements however is that many of
the supplements out there simply do not
contain what's listed on the bottle
and or the quality of the ingredients is
not very high that's why we partnered
with thorn supplements thorn supplements
are used by all the major sports teams
and they've partnered with the mayo
clinic the reason they have so many high
level partners is that thorn supplements
are the very highest quality ingredients
they also are extremely precise in terms
of what's listed on the bottle is always
what's in the bottle if you'd like to
see the thorn supplements that i take
you can go to thorn that's t-h-o-r-n-e
dot com slash the letter u huberman and
there you can see the thorn supplements
that i take and get 20 off any of those
supplements also if you navigate deeper
into the thorn site through that portal
t h o r and e dot com slash the letter u
slash huberman you can also get twenty
percent off any of the other supplements
that thorn makes
if you're not already following us on
instagram and twitter please do so it's
huberman lab on both instagram and
twitter and at those channels i cover
science and science related tools some
of which overlap with the content of
this podcast other of which does not and
is unique content so once again thank
you for joining me for my discussion
with dr david spiegel and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]